we do plan for success so at every
observatory we've ever worked and now at
the Allen telescope array our own
telescope we keep champagne on ice right
we we intend to celebrate if we have a
detection and then of course there's a
lot that needs to be done first you need
to verify that what you've detected is
actually what you think it is and with
SETI because it's so attractive to so
many people you have to worry that it
might be a deliberate hoax so we have to
take precautions and one of the easiest
things to do and one of the the most
sensible things to do is to call up a
telescope to the west of us that that
has the capability to detect the
frequencies that we've detected and ask
them to go looking with their equipment
to see if they see a signal so if they
can confirm that they can see something
with equipment that we didn't build and
software that we didn't right then it's
a pretty good independent confirmation
that it's a real signal and it probably
is exactly what we think it is either
that or it's a whole new brand of
astrophysics that could happen too I
mean we're looking for signals of a
particular type because we don't think
nature can make them if we find that
kind of signal it's either the
engineering we're looking for or
something amazing and knew about nature
so we'll we'll try and get that
independent confirmation then we'll go
through a whole process where we first
send out an iau telegram which is
essentially an email to all the world's
observatories and it says here's what we
found here are the details about the
discovery and any observatory could in
fact choose to look with whatever
equipment they have to see what else
might be there but the other thing that
that does for you is
it informs your scientific colleagues
about the details and these are the
people who are most likely to be
reachable by the world's media and
journalists who when we make an
announcement and we certainly will hold
a press conference and tell the world
when that happens the world's media are
not going to be able to call up the SETI
Institute and get a comment and we don't
want to leave them without some
authoritative source so by sending out
this telegram to the observatories
around the world then the discovery
information is in the hands of people
who can hopefully help interpret it to
to the journalists to the media and we
don't leave them a wash and making up
their own stories so and then of course
we do tell the world we first probably
make some very discreet courtesy calls
to our major donors to let them know
what's happening we've never been asked
to do that but I think as as a as a
thank you we certainly would and then we
try and hold a press conference and try
and make sure that everybody who had
anything to do with the discovery is
appropriately credited and then I don't
know what happens right that's as far as
we go in terms of planning and thinking
we've tried to put a little effort into
G how do we keep our phones working and
our internet up right when we expect a
huge deluge of people wanting to know
more and how the world will react is
it's a guess maybe it will be as Carl
Sagan pictured in in contact maybe it
will be different we've actually held
some some workshops brought in some
experts from from the diplomatic
religious journalistic communities
social scientists and said how will the
world react to this news and you know
the end of the day what could we say we
said that people will react in
accordance with the belief systems that
are in place at the time doesn't tell
you a lot so I guess the other thing
that came out of these workshops was the
importance of trying to educate and
inform people in advance that this is a
possibility this could happen this could
show up on their television screen or in
their newspapers tomorrow and they might
be thinking about what that means for
them and that's some it's another avenue
that we're trying to go down right now
I would be so overwhelmed and excited
simply to have an answer to this old
question even if there is no message
even if it's just kind of a cosmic dial
tone that's a proof of existence I mean
good heads we've answered a question
that we've wondered about for ages and
it's interesting because in this field
the number two is really really critical
so we have one example of life life here
on this planet we don't know about any
other but the moment you get a second
example then you know there are many you
know in physics we sent send account one
to infinity so with a single example it
could be unique the moment you get a
second you know it's abundant and so the
moment that we find that evidence of the
second technology will start looking for
more because we know they're going to be
out there and so understanding actually
how we fit in what the diversity is what
what physics and chemistry have managed
to concoct other places what other kinds
of biology that's what interests me
rather than sending a message about us
I'm really interested in them